saludo en directo américa de france 24
más romeros a la con nosotros en el
estudio marc colombia va lecciónes este
domingo y por ello vamos entonces a
repasar en qué situación se encuentra
ese país en materia de salud buenos días
raúl efectivamente recordemos han sido
dos años de pandemia una pandemia que
aquí en colombia ha dejado
140.000 de muertes casi y más de 6
millones de contagios acumulados también
en cuanto a la vacunación un 70 por
ciento de la población está
completamente vacunado algo lo que la
pone en un nivel relativamente alto en
comparación con el resto del continente
pero vamos más allá del cover vamos a
abrir la óptica para ver cómo está la
situación de salud en colombia de una
forma más general economía es uno de los
países de todo el continente americano
que tiene una cobertura de salud más
amplia el 95 por ciento de su población
está asegurada de alguna forma en los
sistemas de salud pero esa cifra tiene
algunas trampas por ejemplo hay
departamentos regiones del país donde no
llega al 70% otras en cambio de mente
son muy altas y por eso termina ese
cifra a estar ahí qué masa tiene 1,2
médicos por cada 1.000 habitantes
inferior a lo que recomienda la ocde ya
la media de la ocde algo que nos habla
de un déficit de profesionales de la
salud en el país y por último el
gobierno dedica 7,6 por ciento de su pib
a la salud una cifra también
relativamente alta por el continente
respecto a esta cobertura sanitaria
aprovechamos para recordar y explicar un
poco cómo funcionan los regímenes hay un
régimen de contributivo en el que la
persona paga por su salud o su empleador
de acuerdo al salario que gana y un
régimen subsidio subsidiado perdón para
las personas que no pueden costearse ese
precio actualmente más de 20 millones de
colombianos están en este régimen con
subsidiado casi la mitad del país más le
pregunto si entonces el sistema de salud
en colombia es público pues así no
digamos que así lo establece la
legislación pero también establece que
hay prestadores privados que pueden
ofrecer está salud y así al final es
como está sucediendo hoy en día en
colombia se ha derivado en un modelo en
que la mayoría de establecimientos de
hospitales de instalaciones son privadas
empresas de salud que aquí se llaman ips
y que reciben dinero del gobierno para
prestar este servicio que se considera
público esto ha sido a veces ha
criticado podría hacer oscilar un
poquito la balanza hacia un modelo
privado en el que sea más prioritario el
comercio o las ganancias de estas
empresas y no el derecho del acceso a la
salud y de hecho eso durante el año
pasado cuando hubo las protestas del
paro nacional se llegó a tumbar una
reforma de salud que planteaba incluso
caminar un poquito más hacia este modelo
una propuesta que se terminó retirando
por estas protestas masivas además pues
también recordemos que el sistema de
salud colombiano acumula dos años de
pandemia se han multiplicado también las
quejas por ejemplo pues por demoras en
las citas con los especialistas por
problemas en entrega y en cobertura de
medicamentos y también desde los
trabajadores de la salud pues por la
precarización y la sobreexplotación de
esta profesión marc ante esta situación
le pregunto las propuestas entonces ya
de cada candidato presidencial exacto
ahora que tenemos a la imagen en general
vamos a ver qué es lo que proponen
empezamos con rodolfo hernández es un
candidato que se ha llamado populista
que digamos que está en la orilla
ideológica más de la derecha del
centro-derecha vamos a empezar por un
modelo de medicina que plantea o sea más
familiar donde haya más médicos de
familia que hacen seguimiento a los
pacientes también habla de control de
precios de los medicamentos y de
aumentar la producción de vacunas aquí
en colombia locales una medida pues que
se ha comentado mucho por ejemplo para
ser un poquito más soberanos en lo que
respecta a la lucha por ejemplo contra
la pandemia como lo vimos con el commit
19 también habla su programa de mejorar
condiciones laborales en el personal de
salud y una de las propuestas que más ha
sonado ha sido este censo de personas
adictas a sustancias
psicoactivas de una medida que presentó
como una lucha contra el narcotráfico
pero que en realidad pues recordemos que
el gran problema de colombia es la
exportación a otros países de droga pero
bueno tiene una aproximación digamos de
salud pública al tema del uso de las
drogas también renta básica para adultos
mayores algo que podría mejorar el
acceso que tiene esta parte de la
población a la salud para terminar hay
un enfoque en general resumiendo no muy
pensado hacia la gestión que es lo que
le ha caracterizado hacia intentar
acabar con la corrupción revisar los
recursos de la salud pública y sobre dos
temas uno el aborto acorte el reloj
despenalizó hasta la semana 24 en
colombia'
no lo tiene en su programa pero se ha
pronunciado a favor al menos ha dicho
que respetará esa decisión de la corte
aunque hay una cierta desconfianza de
movimientos feministas por otros
comentarios de tono machista que ha
tenido el candidato y sobre la eutanasia
otro de los grandes debates ha dicho que
depende de la gravedad de la enfermedad
que tenga el solicitante por el lado de
gustavo petro marc que podemos ver vamos
al otro candidato en este caso
claramente más de izquierdas digamos que
su viraje más significativo es intentar
cambiar el modelo de salud hacia un
sistema más público no uno que no
dependa de la capacidad de pago de los
contribuyentes sino que sea universal y
de cobertura básica con aportes a través
de impuestos hay quien le ha criticado
que se puede ser realmente difícil pues
de cambiar todo este modelo de salud en
cuatro a cuatro años exactos como
rodolfo a tienen algunos puntos en común
por ejemplo de hablar de potenciar la
industria farmacéutica y también de
mejorar las condiciones laborales
por otra parte habla de involucrar los
saberes ancestrales los haberes
tradicionales de los pueblos originarios
de colombia también de los
afrodescendientes en unos sistemas pues
que se coordinan con los sistemas más
tradicionales en el sistema occidental
de la palabra digamos y por último una
propuesta que ya implementó en colombia
los médicos al hogar que es que
profesionales se desplazan es una
propuesta que él pone como para intentar
evitar que haya esa falta de cobertura
sanitaria en zonas pues más apartadas de
colombia para terminar algunas otras
propuestas que vamos a destacar por
ejemplo de nuevo es que si tiene un
claro apoyo al derecho al aborto y al
respeto a la decisión de la corte al
respecto de esas 24 semanas en general
tiene un enfoque de los derechos pues
sexuales y reproductivos de las mujeres
en sus planes de salud y también
destacamos que propone tener apoyo
médico y psicosocial al tránsito de
género para las personas que quieran que
quieran hacerlo entonces pues bueno esas
son algunas de las propuestas que
también nos propone gustavo petro vamos
a ver entonces cuál de estas propuestas
gana en las elecciones del día domingo
mar máxima gracias haremos la semana que
viene claro por supuesto que sí gracias
como siempre más por toda la información
de salud nos vemos el lunes con más